first tonight we begin
with the bizarre baffling and
bewildering blunders well
they are apparently run in the family of
joe biden because first lady jill biden
under more fire tonight after comparing
hispanic americans to tacos while
yesterday speaking at a latin x event
this time in san antonio take a look
raul helped build this organization
with the understanding that the
diversity of this community as distinct
as the bogotas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san
antonio right now those remarks prompted
massive backlash from hard-working
latinos from all across the country
including from the national association
of hispanic journalists they said in a
statement quote we are not tacos and the
criticism was so bad the first lady's
office they were forced to shell out an
apology with one staffer tweeting quote
the first lady apologizes that her
conveyed words that she conveyed
anything but pure admiration and love
for the latino community but that's uh
done very little to quell the
controversy because even the ladies on
that hard-hitting news show the view
they couldn't help but finally admit
that jill biden totally messed up in a
pretty major way take a look
you think somebody might have read the
speech
beforehand and said maybe you don't want
to say it like this yeah but this is you
know i i
i won't even say what i what it is
because it's you know we all step and
poo from time to time pro tip when
speaking to hispanics really really
avoid any comparisons to tacos
enchiladas chimichangas
yeah and and
that was the racial stereotype that she
used racial stereotype so i don't know
who wrote that for but and it was such
an unforced error
right of course it couldn't come at a
worse time for the imploding biden white
house and the extreme democratic party
the latest new york times sienna poll
finding that joe's popularity with
hispanic americans is tanking like never
before pretty much with every other
demographic as well a whopping 54
percent of hispanic voters disapproving
of joe biden's job performance other
polls have it even higher and it's why
republican and hispanic candidates
they're surging and they're winning all
across the country we told you about the
race in south texas where congresswoman
flores won a texas special election
district that had been dominated by
democrat democrats for the last 150
years and if all that wasn't bad enough
for democrats here's joe yet again
appearing to joke about not knowing who
the president is take a look
folks uh
you know you don't have to stand every
time i hear hail of the chief wonder
where the hell is
it took me a long while you think i'm
joking i'm not
turn around on where where's the
president
yep a lot of americans are asking the
same question where is a strong
president anyway joe's presidency
collapsing your own party his party
doesn't want him to run and you think
it's uh maybe a good time to joke listen
to this biden word salad when asked
about 2024 take a look at this mr
president what's your message to
democrats who don't want you to run
again
they want me to run people two thirds
read the polls
read the polls jack you guys are all the
same that poll
showed that 92 percent of democrats of
iran would vote for me
all right the biden presidency is
failing so much so fast that even the
media mob they're being forced to reckon
with the reality that they helped create
look at this new opinion piece from the
new york times entitled joe biden is too
old to be president again new york
magazine taking things even a step
further pondering how biden can be
pushed aside even if he tries to run for
re-election in 2024 the article bluntly
asks the question are democrats stuck
with biden harris 24 anyway strange to
say but they might be so the biden white
house is getting so desperate so
delusional that failing press secretary
karine jean-pierre is now resorting to
kind of like circle back gensake
playbook and and flat out making things
up now here's jean-pierre falsely
claiming biden's approval ratings among
democrats is a whopping 92 percent which
is a complete lie because over
two-thirds don't want him to run in some
cases higher take a look
what was the president's response to a
new poll from the new york times today
showing that 64 of democrats say that
they would prefer a different candidate
in 2024 and i would also say from that
very same poll there were 92 percent of
democrats who uh support this president
as well look you know not to be not get
into uh you know politics from here or
get into any political analysis
you know this is not something
you know there's going to be many polls
they're going to go up and they're going
to go down
this is not the thing that we are solely
focused on
so as the new york times poll found
biden's approval among his own party has
now crashed to 70 percent even his
radical far left base becoming more and
more dissatisfied with the disarray
coming out of the white house this comes
as biden will soon now he's departing
for saudi arabia where we know it's
going to happen he will kiss the ring of
the crown prince that he said
murdered
journalist jamal khashoggi and the
nation that he called the pariah nation
during the campaign so now all of a
sudden we need a good relationship with
the pariah nation with the murdering
crown prince
joe you don't have to beg texas oklahoma
north dakota for more oil are you going
to beg the pariah saudis and the crown
prince murderer to produce more oil
because you won't produce it
domestically and tomorrow we get the
consumer price index inflation data it's
expected to be another 40-year plus high
record as americans now we're all
suffering under the cost of biden's
climate religious cult agenda hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else